[Music]
in friends over politics news submitted
by remember to hydrate Ellen DeGeneres
Ellen DeGeneres defends her friendship
with George W Bush I always saw this is
so cool yeah apparently been canceled
she's homies with them yeah yeah and she
she's like yeah so I'll show you should
be friends we pull them once I feel
pulling top well what is it saying
attention Oh Texas you can't really
remember yeah you can't remember yeah so
Ellen DeGeneres did this monologue thing
on her show
after she attended a Cowboys Packers
game over the weekend because it there
were images there were there were photos
of Ellen sitting next to George daddy
George wh Libya and so she ended up
talking about it defending it so this is
she got canceled for being my friend
this is what it
the box seats maybe during the game they
showed a shot of George and me laughing
together and so people were upset they
thought why is it gay Hollywood liberal
sitting next to a conservative
Republican president didn't even notice
I'm holding the brand new iPhone 11 but
a lot of people were mad and they did
what people do when they're mad they
tweet and but here's one tweet that I
loved this person says Ellen and George
Bush together makes me have faith in
America again here's the thing I'm
friends with George Bush in fact I'm
friends with a lot of people who don't
share the same beliefs that I have we're
all different and I think that we've
forgotten that that's okay that we're
all different for instance I wish people
wouldn't wear fur
I don't like it but but I'm friends with
people who wear fur and I'm friends with
people who are furry as a matter of fact
friends who should tweeze more and I I
have but just because I don't agree with
someone on everything doesn't mean that
I'm not gonna be friends with them when
I say be kind to one another I don't
mean only the people that think the same
way that you do I mean be kind to
everyone
yeah so she got canceled again and that
didn't she was yeah i phone 11 though
yeah that's it tight it's scary as [ __ ]
get those cameras away I know there's
like too many cameras so you've been
after that her defending it people are
still like nah but you can't be friends
with hands well is that the main reason
why is because he's a conservative
president no cuz he all right yeah keep
going
go ahead tip tip words the answers but
I'm not sure right no okay so it's
mainly because okay so for example Mark
Ruffalo tweeted this out he said sorry
until George W Bush is brought to
justice for the crimes of the Iraq war
including american-led torture Iraqi
deaths and display
man and the deep scar is emotional and
and otherwise inflicted expulsion of
cherry that served his folly fully he we
can't even begin to talk about kindness
son that's like one perspective another
point that a lot of people are bringing
up is how Ellen DeGeneres in their eyes
is a hypocrite because she has banned
multiple people from from appearing on
her show
because they didn't align with her
beliefs so like who know like for
example Caitlyn Jenner it was one of
them where she said some stuff in the
past and then she banned her but then
eventually she ended up going on her
show but there's a there's a list of
people I didn't I didn't save that list
because I didn't think it was yeah yeah
yeah like needed to dive deep into it
but a lot of people are saying like well
that's you're being a hypocrite and also
he has war crimes he needs to yeah I
thought that's more the reason why
people hated george w bush than anything
is his proxy war is fake war his his
whole family and company getting rich
off of the oil that they stole and then
all the people that had to die for it i
don't really know if it's his ideals or
anything about gay or whatever i think
that's what most people don't like him
for that don't like him right and and so
i don't know it's just kind of weird
that I like her message it is true
because overall if someone has
conflicting views from you it's
different but then I think in this
particular case he had he had a really
bad rep because it wasn't just like a
president that said weird [ __ ] so yeah I
don't know how to I don't know yes even
people who have supported Ellen after
she came out with this thing like hey
like one example is Kristen Bell she
posted her on her on her Instagram
account and she wrote she's my queen and
like doing a whole bunch of emojis and
she even took that down because
people were like she didn't even add
Ellen she didn't even at her in the
twitch tweet no yeah on her Instagram so
Kristen Bell took it down because people
were upset that Kristen Bell supported
Ellen defending the friendship and then
um and the people are saying like oh
this reeks of privilege to Reese
Witherspoon who tweeted thank you for
this important reminder Ellen
so people are even upset at other people
like yeah coming into the conversation
yeah I think we're where I saw this clip
was actually on Anthony Robbins of
Instagram or Tony Robbins our friend
yeah so what was he saying he just
posted that clip and then he did I like
her message because right now we do need
that like conservatives and liberals are
so yeah so far apart and and I mean just
if there it is cancel culture right it's
like oh you don't believe what I believe
in you're the devil
[ __ ] you yeah I agree too like when I
was seeing that I'm like yeah that's
dope you know be friends with different
views but then I guess there is a line
that a lot of people feel like well that
just crosses the line like this person
and there's a horrible person that
doesn't deserve any any form of kindness
I how a lot of people felt strongly
about it yeah I mean like ultimately I
don't really know if this is true but I
think it is kind of common knowledge or
there's a huge suspicion that him and
Cheney made a [ __ ] ton of money off of
the war and so that to me is like is was
America your priority or was your caucus
yeah was Halliburton and and and you
know Texaco or whatever your what was
the word they the priorities or was
America your priority so I don't know
like how to make sense of all of that
if he just had different ideas to me
that's different yeah completely but
then the fact that I feel that people
had to die unnecessarily for profit
that's where I go oh man I'll feel good
about this really they're saying that so
since long since Bush
launched the war on terror in 2001
it has since killed around 250,000
civilians in those three countries of
Iraq Afghanistan and those numbers are
fabricated because it's way bigger than
that because those according to Brown
University study in 2018 right but
they're using statistics based off of
the military but what the military does
is when they do drone strikes or kills
they are associates of terrorists even
though if it's a mistake and it killed a
civilian so those numbers it's way
bigger yeah cuz they're saying here like
there have been more than a hundred
Pakistani children killed by 51 CIA
drone strikes by Bush since or between
2004 and the start of 2009 if that's one
secure and so like I might I might get
cancelled for this but I also think that
you know if you go with Republican
presidents our president right now Trump
hasn't even done anything close to what
George W Bush did as far as war goes
right or like killing goes and all that
stuff so I don't know like it's hard for
me to if I saw Ellen with with Donald
Trump I wouldn't I think that would be
it's a little bit more yeah cuz it's
like it's like yeah he is a conservative
and he says misogynistic things but you
know what I'm cool we have different
ideas there's yeah there's there's drone
strikes all throughout so it's it's it's
literally not been you know it's not
it's not a mystery that is even now you
know it's happy because it's a
continuation of you know the war on
terror that's terrible yeah I had a
friend who like a group of friends and
two of them were really close and like I
know them one really well and then the
other one he always had problems with
drugs and alcohol and he was still my
friend I would consider him my friend
but I wasn't as close as other people
were in our group and he went on to
continue like having problems with
alcohol and drugs and he got in a car
and killed another person as
driving and so the friend who is I'm
closer with but it's really close with
him she kind of came out and said you
know my friend did this really awful
thing but I know he like he's not a good
person but he's still my friend and he's
still alive thankfully and I know he
deserves like he's in jail now she's
like I know he deserves this and he's
gonna like pay for what he did but I
can't just abandon him because of
something so terrible that he did like
I'm not close enough with him to like
really take that stance cuz it's
confusing for me I always felt weird
about our friendship because he would
like be drinking around me and I
wouldn't know how to act whereas she
kind of can relate a little bit more but
I thought that was cool of her to take
someone who did something like
despicable and still show some
compassion and like let them know that
even though you are a shitty person I'm
still there for you because I don't
think a shitty person can ever like come
around to changing unless they have
that's true you know that is loyalty and
I can respect that because it's like if
you had friends who are like former mob
guys or whatever and then you know they
or some guys maybe are still in it and
doing the dirt you might have changed
but you still if they're still your
friends you might pick them over
strangers so in this case it might be
that like they might be friends and
she's like George you got to stop
[ __ ] doing that [ __ ] you know he's
like I can't I got oil I like oil and
ignore it too all the stuff that is
great cuz like yeah so you don't know we
really don't know I'm like I agree with
it or would you say Illuminati well I
said conspiracy theory she's like
involved in it because they're all
making money from that [ __ ] I can't talk
about forever and I kind of see though
how like maybe she does have a grander
plan of trying to change things in
politics and it's like maybe she feels
like that's not gonna happen unless I'm
there having these conversations and
showing what I can fight for or giving a
different perspective that's true that's
true when all these people when Trump
got into office and all these
politicians
just like abandoned ship not all of them
but a lot of them abandon ship like I
don't want to work with this guy
the people who stepped up and realized
like I don't want to work with this guy
but I need to be there because it's my
job and like my duty as a public servant
I think that's something where it's like
you do have to create friendships with
people who are in power
regardless of how you may feel about
them oh yeah that's the more effective
way actually like we're gonna keep the
ships closer you are to the king even if
you don't like them the more influence
you have over that king so I mean you
could either do that or lose that power
in that influence and go it go it goes
against my belief and then you leave and
you lose your power that you had over
decision-making or whatever so some it's
I mean this stuff is not easy right so
like you know the feelings I have toward
the former president you know that's
just me for my peasant mind looking up I
don't know his situation he probably had
to choose from worse to worse you know
like who knows really yeah but it's
interesting and I love conspiracies
[Music]
[Music]